allez direction Blois et le centre
hospitalier depuis le 21 juillet dernier
une nouvelle approche est mise en œuvre
par les soignants pour que les actes
médicaux soient le moins traumatisant
possible pour les enfants le principe
est de détourner leur attention
stimulant leur sens l'outil à
disposition du personnel est une bobo
mobile découverte dans ce reportage de
depuis le 21 juillet le service des
urgences pédiatriques de Blois dispose
d'un nouvel équipement ce chariot
roulant est une bobo mobile il regorge
d'outils adaptés pour distraire l'enfant
lorsque l'on doit réaliser sur lui un
acte médical ce matin-là il faut
effectuer une prise de sang sur maelia
pour limiter son anxiété et sa douleur
les deux infirmières vont stimuler ces
sens
tu as une porte secrète parce que
Blanche-Neige dans sa chambre elle a une
porte secrète la prise de sang est
finalement réalisée avec l'usage du
protoxyde d'azote le fameux gaz hilarant
mais sans pleurs de la petite fille un
bon point pour les prochaines fois car
l'enfant ne gardera pas à un mauvais
souvenir de cette expérience
elle connaît pas les médecins donc c'est
vrai que ça a pas mal détourné c'est un
peu compliqué bien sûr parce que après
chaque enfant est différent donc c'est
pour ça ils ont pas mal de de jouer pour
les occuper et je pense que ça s'est
bien passé
le dispositif peut s'adapter à chaque
enfant et à sa sensibilité
l'intervention réussie est celle qui ne
laissera pas de séquelles psychologique
l'enfant il ressent la douleur et après
ça peut rester encré et ça c'est
vraiment quelque chose où il faut que
nous on Vienne travailler pour pour
améliorer et pour limiter cette
sensation là et le traumatisme plus tard
maelia repart toute souriante avec son
masque parfumé à la menthe à terme la
soixantaine d'infirmières de
puéricultrice et d'auxiliaires de
puériculture du service blésois de
pédiatrie seront formés à cette nouvelle
approche